hello everyone my name is Franklin
Velasquez and today we're going to be
talk
- suo I saw 3 a dremel with Python just
to give me an idea who's familiar here
with a dremel or out of Matic machine
learning is anyone ok ok what about with
the library issue oh ok ok so a few
people know
ok so today I want to do a brief
introduction to s 2 or 3 and then brief
introduction to automatic machine
learning and and then we're going to be
doing an arrow ml tutorial in Python as
well as flow so as the introduction to
version 3
this is a fully open source distributed
memory machine learning platform s 2 or
3 is fully open source distributed in
memory machine learning platform it has
can be integrated with big ecosystems
such as Hadoop and also Apache spark and
to add a little bit more to this we also
have the product called h2o sparkling
water which is a combination of spark
and actually well we also have the very
flexible interface we have integration
with our Scala Java suo flow and what
we're going to be doing today Python it
provides very good paths and smart
algorithms and I will be talking about
them shortly it has very provides very
good performance because of the
distributor in-memory computing platform
and also the distributor algorithms it
also provides highly you're in rapid
model deployment soo allows you to
convert the models that you built to
either plain old Java objects or pojos
and model object optimized which are
also known as modules and they are very
they are very portable so they are very
easy to deploy
we also have the GPU an element most of
the neural networks work much faster
with GPUs than CPUs and also actual
provides a cloud integration we can you
can integrate it with Amazon Web service
Google cloud or Microsoft feature so why
is too low 3/4 Python and machine
learning so one is the speed you have
very fast training and inferencing the
algorithms are very accurate is very
scalable and very easy and we will see
this with the original today so some of
the algorithms that we provide our our
show here the statistical learning or
statistical analysis which includes
panelists linear systems this includes
general linear models with a l1 and l2
regressions and also provides a
combination of both which is the elastic
net we also have in the statistical
analysis the knife base algorithm and
then in the decision tree ensembles we
have distributed random forests gradient
boosting machines and extreme gradient
boosting or more commonly known as XE
boost we also provide stacking or stock
on symbols and I'm going to talk a
little bit more about this later on as
we go into that we also have the a demo
which is what we're going to be doing
today and for neural networks we have
both deep neural networks such as in a
multi-layer perceptron and also for deep
learning we have a convolution now nor
networks by you have to be with the GPU
enable to be used to use that one and on
the unsupervised learning we have a
clustering for k-means those
have dimensionality reduction such as a
principal component analysis or PCA and
also generalized lower rank models and
this is just an extension of the ideal
PCA then we also have aggregator which
creates smaller data sets from larger
data sets and the last two are anomaly
detection we have our encoders are dual
encoders which find outliers using
nonlinear dimensionality reduction and
the last one turns embedding is for the
word to bag which means that when you
have a column with a text you can
convert the text to vectors that way you
can use that for your algorithms so if
you're familiar with pandas or psyche
learn the syntax for h2o is going to be
very familiar you can see here in the
first one when we read the data with the
pandas you usually do that read
underscore CSV you provide the data path
for this below you will use the import
underscore file and provide the data
path and you you don't have to specify
the datatype issuable recognize it for
you so I know in pandas you have to do
read underscore CSV or Excel but I saw a
lot you to just import the file without
the need to specify and also you can see
the describe function we it's also a
natural as well as the mean and you can
go through all this later on if you want
but I want to focus or show you also the
building that model this is the way you
will build a random forests in cycle
learn so you usually call the classifier
and then you define the number of
estimators that you want and then use
the fit the fit function and you provide
the extreme and the wireframe in in the
side of vegetable
you import the or you bring in the or
you call the the classifier they random
for us and will you specify as well the
parameter number of trees which is the
same as the number of estimators and
then you use a train function and then
you pass your ex and Y and your train
frame your x and y i don't have to be
there frames it's just the strength of
the names or a list of the names that
you want for your X and your Y and you
will see this when we do the handsome
part and then you have the predictions
you you see we have the same the same
function and to retrieve the metrics you
also do you can do a model performance
and if you have a test that you you
assign it to it and then you print you
can print various metrics such as the a
you see for example la claws and those
are for classifications and you can also
do our MSC and ma e and we'll be doing
some of this in the hands-on part so a
little bit sample of power you read the
data into the suo first Python user will
use the import file as I've mentioned
before and then the Python client will
make an HTTP call to the ESOL cluster
and here you can see that to write you
we have a natural cluster with three
notes and when when you make the request
they all three will try to bring in the
data and this will happen in parallel
that way everything is working at the
same time and once you have the data and
your closer the Python client will have
a pointer and what we see in Python will
be a data frame but in the actual closer
will be distributed so feel free to stop
me at any point with questions or
comment so with this short introduction
to visual I want to talk about
so some aspects of machine learning that
can be automated our data prep model
generation and ensembles for data prep
we have feature engineering data munging
and all the preparation that you usually
do to your data before fitting it to the
model and then we have the model
generation where you choose your model
you tune it and and then you go to the
ensembles if you're familiar with
ensembles you will know that most of the
time they are performed single models
because this is a combination of various
models so for example you can have in
the ensemble's with a linear model the
decision tree and maybe a deep learning
model so and that will usually perform
better than just a single algorithm so a
little bit more details about the data
processing we have imputation encoding
standardization feature selection such
as PC a target encoding we also have for
the model generation as I said you do
hyper parameter tuning you can do
Cartesian grid search or a random grid
search and all these ways to find the
perfect or not a perfect but the most
accurate model and then you have the
unsampled here we see two two different
samples one is the stacking which is
what actual does and this is a pretty
much brings all the the algorithms
together and with a another
meta-learning
it does trains them and doing kind of
like machine learning within machine
learning and then the ensemble selection
is just adding or removing the models to
until you see that the performance
improves
so with this in mind I want to talk a
little bit about the goals of our ml so
the goals are to train the best models
and they listen one of time and also to
reduce human effort and expertise
required in machine learning this two
goals are very like they go by hand
because when you're trying to tune a
model you will usually spend some time
trying to say I'm thinking about random
forest say you you'll have to tune the
number of trees the debt and and if
you're a data scientist then you might
know which parameters to tune right but
if you don't really know much about the
algorithm it would be hard it will
you'll spend a lot of time and maybe we
won't get like a very good result but
our ml will train the models for you and
actually give them to use that way you
can do the statistical analysis at the
end so with this also
Adamo improves the performance of
machine learning models as I said before
because it does the grid search in
tuning the models for you and the last
one which I consider a very important
one to increase reproducibility and to
establish a baseline baseline for
scientific research so some people might
use I don't know - they will train it
for some time and that will get the best
model and from there to local research
so that way you further improve the
performance of your model or you can do
just give it enough time - you're a
dremel and use that for for your for
your model so the issue of a dremel
pipeline it's follow it provides a light
data preparation it also does the model
generation for you as well as the stock
ensembles and I'll be talking a little
bit details about this so we impute
missing data standardized numeric
pictures and why hot and cold
categorical features
so this is not just for a demo but this
is in general for all the algorithms in
the shul
so every time you do you use suo with
any algorithm this is being done
automatically for you and then we have
the model generation and our ml will
explore different algorithms such as
GLM's random forests DBMS and deep
neural networks and also XE boost it
does a perform random grid search over a
high parameter over your hyper parameter
space so they use it says set space that
it's already defined so it will look for
the it will try to tune the important
parameters based on the on your data set
and we also use early stopping rules for
models and the grid so if data most is
that I the metric is not improving it
will just stop even if you give it like
too much time so this and lastly the
second symbols other model creates two
more models since on top of the models
that you want to create one is stacking
symbol of all models so say if you're a
dermal has ten models at the end you
will have 12 because you will create two
model to more stagnant symbols and one
will become will have all the models in
your are ml and then you have the best
model for each algorithm oh the best
yeah the best model for each algorithm
so meaning that if you give it enough
time to Train GBM vegetables model
deep learning you will see all of this
in in in this Stockton sample and we
will see this right now in our in the
hands-on part so short recap we have for
a demo we have based basic data
processing as in all algos eronel trains
a random grid search of gbm's deep
neural networks GLM's
XE booze and and also does individual
models tuning with that cross validation
so cross validation is also done
automatically for you you don't have to
specify anything and this is used for
the stacked and symbols as well and here
you get the Oldham all models ensemble
and and the best of family ensemble and
we also return our ml will return the
leaderboard with all the models and all
the models can be easily exported to
production this is done with the module
and module as I mentioned before are
there any questions yes so that's done
with the with the hyperparameters that
is done with the with the already set a
grid search that it's been already coded
into the well we also we're doing also a
cross validation so that also helps you
make sure that the model is no
overfitting so we're we don't we're not
we don't have time series at this point
for our ml yes any any more questions
yes
I will have to get back to you but yeah
we do have a different flower
integrations as I mentioned before so I
saw it does work with iCloud AWS and
Microsoft Azure so yeah
are there so so here are some benchmarks
for our ml and h2o so if you want once
you once you get the slides you you can
visit them and these are for the open
source so you don't have to trust me you
can go to this benchmarks and see then
the result for yourself
and here it's some training material
some tutorials and documentation that
might be helpful if you want to look at
it so let's get to the hands-on part so
let's let's go to to aquarium that h2o
that AI slash login so I will ask you if
you can create an account and don't
worry this is uh this just for an online
environment that you will be using so a
link is aquarium that I showed that AI
slash login so it's aquarium that is
tool that AI slash login so once you log
in its everyone at the aquarium page
yes okay so one more thing I will ask
you to go to this repo on github
the link is github.com slash Frank J BA
/ - tutorials and we will download the
superior notebook from there so yes so
this link right here so k hub calm slice
from GV a slice - OH - tutorials so so
if you if you're there allows you to go
to the introduction to machine learning
and then you will do a right click on
raw and Save Link As
so once again once you're in the
introduction to machine learning with
SEO part three click on raw and Save
Link As and it will give you the option
to download it and just choose somewhere
where you can find it easily because
we're going to upload this to the
aquarium environment right now so it's
everyone with me do you have the file
yes okay so let's go to let me just do
it to save it so once you're in the
aquarium click on browse labs so when
you click on browse labs go all the way
down to the lab ID 13 and click on View
details so once again once you're in the
labs go all the way down to lab ID 13
which is called a sword area coursework
and click on View details and start a
lab so when you start the lab you'll be
able to act
you better URL so click on it and it
will open the environment for you yes so
use h2o h2o again all the letter O and
not 0 so now it's just a regular it's
just lowercase it's just h2o for the
token
and you should have access now it's
everyone with me in the Jupiter no book
now yes
okay good so we're going to upload the
file so in the right in your right hand
side next to new do upload file and look
for the file that we just downloaded and
open it and then just do the upload so
I'll give you a few seconds
so it's everyone with me can we continue
yes okay so click on the yeah click on
the Jupiter notebook that we just
uploaded and she'll take us to the
instance yes so if you're familiar with
you paired notebook will just be running
this notebook with the shift-enter
so this part is going to be really easy
for you but the next part will be more
interesting you will be doing more
clicking actually so let's run the first
line in the first line we were just
importing some libraries that we would
be using we're not going to be using
everything in detail but um we are doing
some plots so run the second line and
this will check if what if we if the
environment if we're in and the aquarium
and the third line should open or
actually in open you're in science so so
we're just initializing or actual closer
and what's everyone able to get to the
third cell with no errors so while we
get there
here's the cluster information the that
actual will provide provide you so
here's some basic just how how much time
he has been running the version of
vegetable how many notes in the
presentation I show you a closer with
three but right now with just one we
have a 14 gigs of memory and we have 16
cores that are we're going to be using
and this is all in the environment and
and so if we all there we are going to
import the pile so run the next cell and
right here we have the our file in s3
bucket so we're just providing the link
and as you can see we're using the
import file command and it will just
bring the data so we're using that data
set that comes from the Freddie Mac and
contains twenty years of mortgage
history and it's sample represents a
loan and this each loan has a different
type of all these columns which include
credit score the first payment date some
interest rate also if you you can scroll
if you run the fifth sale you can scroll
down to two all the way to a right and
you will see a service name if it's been
prepaid or this called delinquent so in
this tutorial we're going to be using a
dremel to to predict if a loan will be
delinquent or not and we'll also be
doing a regression case which will be
predicting the interest rate and we'll
see more details about it
so several everyone with me at this
point
yes awesome yes okay so next oh by the
way this is the head command this is
that same that I you see in in pandas it
will display the first ten rows for you
and you can change the number inside
that way you can print how many rows
that you want we also have the describe
which will give you an aesthetical
analysis are short the statistical
summary of your of your data set as you
can see here this data set has about
50,000 column rose I'm sorry and 27
columns and here you can see the type of
each column the minimum value they mean
the max the standard deviation the
series in and the missing values and
also you get the first ten
columns with this command so let's take
a close look to the delinquent column
and we're just doing the this is the
name of our frame a so frame and we are
accessing the delinquent column right
here with this command and we'll just
print a table so this gives that the
distribution so as you can see most most
loans in this case are good loans or are
not delinquent and those are very few
percentage is is labeled as true and
this is means that we have a very
imbalanced data set so we will see
something that might help our
predictions when we do the arrow ml so
next let's take a look at the interest
rate as well and as you can see we're
doing the same thing it's just that now
we're accessing the original interest
rate and we're doing the histogram at
the end yes
oh well our ml will do something that
has a whole sample differently but even
solve the entire problem so more
advanced feature engineering or more
data prep will be needed but in this
tutorial we just want to show the other
malfunction so so maybe the result won't
be the perfect or the best results but
you will see the capabilities so far I
don't know so does that answer your
question yes so so yes so so for some
some of the for the numbers the missing
values are the suo uses they mean value
for those and for categorical values it
will use it will make them as a new
category so it won't see the missing
value as something that is missing data
but I will see it as something that is
left like that on purpose so does that
answer your question yes okay so so we
will split the data set into two frames
we will do a train and test and you can
see this very simple we're using the
frame command and the way we specify the
ratio it's inside inside bracket and we
can't we just have to show one of them
which is the percentage for our train
set so we are given 80% of the data set
to a train frame and 20% for the test
set and we are also specifying the seat
just for our reproducibility purposes
and here the next line you can print
distribution so we see that we also we
have almost 40,000 rows for our
training set and about 10,000 for our
test set so we'll be using that for for
to train our uh terminal and this is
where we will define our Y and X values
so as I said before you don't have to
pass the entire you don't have to split
your your training or test that into x
and y frame you will just give the name
of the columns to the algorithm and they
will recognize it for you for example
we're doing y is equal to delinquent and
for x we're doing all of the column
except this for
so we're knowing the response also
prepaid because this is a clear
indication that if a loan will be
delinquent or not and as well as a
prepaid prepayment penalty and the
product type is just a constant column
so it won't help at all so if you run it
it will create these two variables for
you your Y in your X and then we can
print one more time the distribution in
the test so to make sure that I'm the
the test the split function actually
tries to have the same distribution as
the original data set if you remember
right here we have about 3.6 percent but
now we have about 2.9 almost four
percent so you can see it's very close
but the the labels that true labels are
very it's very very small amount so so
with that let's run our our ml and we'll
give it 5 min five minutes so while
that's running I will do some
explanation and take more questions if
you have any so there are several
parameters that you can set that you
don't have to the only required ones are
a your age your Y in the
training frame for the for the train
function for the arrow mode you can run
the the default one but the default one
runs for an hour and right now we just
want to I just want to get to show you
all the all these functions for our ml
so which is doing five five minutes or
300 seconds then we can also specify the
seed we can give it a project name that
way it's easy to retrieve it after and
here's the command that I was talking
about the balance classes so we're
setting this to true and again for the
Train we just have X Y or Y and a train
frame we can have a leaderboard frame
and what it will do we will sort your
leaderboard based on the that frame or
our test frame but I want to show you
first the the the leaderboard with the
cross-validation scores and then we'll
we'll take a closer look at the model
performance in based on the test set so
while this is running are there any
questions yes
so the way it does it I will over sample
the minority class or under sample so
you can specify this in this case we
haven't done that we're just letting the
issue do it for itself
but if you wanted to get more accurate
and to that you will have to try to find
it for yourself you you will specify how
you want to sample it and and also you
have another command which is to how how
much more you want the data set to to
grow like your data frame yes yeah so in
the slides I showed the benchmark and
that's uh yes the benchmark so here this
uh terminal has a comparison of all
these are ml open sources so feel free
to go over it and it has the comparison
between all this other model and how suo
performs yes any any more questions I
think it's all one in the back no ok so
there just want to mention some other
parameters that you can set but you
don't have to as I say it out you can
run your animal as default and or also
just restrict the time that way it won't
take forever but you can have a
validation frame a leaderboard frame you
can also have in your columns or or
hours or metric and we will have
actually that one in the next algorithm
we also have exclude algos and include
algis so in case you want to make sure
that
and the specific algorithm is including
you will use include Algol and write the
name of the algorithm that you want or
if you just want to exclude an algorithm
you will just specify that to say say
you you don't like deep neural networks
because they take longer to train then
you can just exclude them from your
other mail yes yeah so as to what does
it for you so when you get your your
data you can have it as a as so go back
to see if we go back to the our describe
you can see the type and this ennum is
the what the actual calls the
categorical features so for right now
we're choosing a link win which is a
true-and-false so so that
so so as I said everything is in the in
the issue a closer so I personally
haven't experienced that yet but um
since everything is done in the in the
memory if you give it if you give enough
memory to closer then you won't have any
problem oh it's one - Gordon yes sorry
yes
yeah so in in this idle mode there is no
feature engineering a still hasn't been
implemented so any advanced data
manipulation or feature engineering will
have to be done by you by the user and
then you will just give it to the model
so it's it's done so if everyone's with
me we can print the leaderboard now and
you will see that we have several models
that were trained in just five minutes
so the the best model is the está con
symbol as I mentioned before of the
vessel family which means that it will
have one of each each of this models in
it so again for for the leader board
each of your model that leader board and
that will print it but in here we're
doing a two lines we're doing two lines
just to make sure that we print all the
models that were trained for our ml so
you can see that I'm the the first extra
boost did bad with AUC of 0.63 but the
Stockton symbol which combines all those
the best model from its family is doing
much better than that so let's take a
close look to the stagnant symbol the
best family which was our best model so
here we're just retrieving getting the
models ID so if you run it at the end
you will see this all the the models
that are part of the Stockton symbol so
we have model like this and then we just
check for a Stockton symbol and right
here with just plotting our actually
printing the coefficients so you can see
that this a Stockton symbol best family
has an the extra booze has a GLM a TBM a
tip learning
extreme random for it and I did should
be running for us I'm sorry and extreme
run randomizer trees which is just a
another form of a random forest and we
can plot it so if you run the next line
we will see that the XC boost underscore
three is the model that is most helpful
for this is tucked and symbol followed
by the GLM and the deep learning and
lastly the that DRF the the xrt and the
GBM are not really contributing too much
so here's how we do the model
performance based on the test set so if
you run it you will see that what we're
doing here we're taking the leader from
our leader board this is just the in the
model that we name it yes so the AML
then leader and then the function is
model performance and we're given a test
set because we want to see how it
perform on the test set that we set
apart at the beginning so since this is
a classification problem we can take a
look at the AUC and also de la gloss so
you can see that the AUC is eighty two
point three compared to the 85 that we
see from the cross-validation so the
cross-validation actually reflects we
can say that it reflects the disc or
from from unseen data but then we also
have to look at the confusion matrix
because I say as I said the the data was
heavily imbalance and we can see their
reflection in here because the error for
the true label it's point six nine so
it's quite high but we can see that the
false is point zero three and overall is
point zero five
so about Pipers
so it will depend on what your
application is here you can see all the
maximum metrics their respective
thresholds so if you're trying to
maximize the f1 you will use this this
value or if you were trying to if you
just care about maximizing the accuracy
this model can give you max accuracy of
point nine six with distressful and and
so on this varies with the with the with
your applications as I say so if you
wanted to maximize any of this depending
on your application you will you can
just change your your thresholds we also
get a again some lift table as part of
the summary and we can also plot the ROC
curve and here we see the AUC value that
we got before and this is just a nice
representation that way we can see how
the model is doing and it was it's easy
for us to deduce that the AUC is 82 it's
no higher because of the imbalance data
set we can also do predictions so if we
run this one you will see that you will
see a table and you will see two
probabilities you will see a probability
of being false and being true and then
the first column
it's the predict so or your prediction
and this this this prediction is based
on the trifle that maximizes the f1 so
up here we can see that the trade-off
for that maximizes f1 is point one two
about point one one three so if they
truly will were to be higher than that
trifle the prediction will be true so
yeah so you can you as well lets you add
custom scores so you can bring that so I
don't I personally don't know how you
write the function for money right but
you you can do it in this so you can
bring custom scores any more question
yes so we will see that in the
regression case yeah so so so this is
what I wanted to cover for the
classification I know we went really
fast but I wanted to cover like most of
this material but it does anyone have
more questions yes
for what I'm sorry
I don't think and it's that kind of like
the the stopping metric would you
consider that or now
okay
yeah okay so so we'll move on then to
the regression use case again we can see
the the same the same same syntax which
is defining our Y and our X and we're at
this time at this point we're ignoring
mohr-coulomb because when we're trying
to predict the interest rate we wouldn't
have all this all this information when
trying to give an interest rate for a
loan so if you run it you can also okay
okay so so here we have our X Y and our
X so these are all the columns that are
going to be part of our predictor and
let's run it one more time so right now
we're going to be using a regression and
see how we didn't have to specify
anything to tell they all do a
regression or do a classification
because h2o actually or our ml will will
deduce this from from your response
column so if you have a caracal
categorical response then you will do a
classification but if you have an int I
will do a regression was there in a
question yeah okay
so so you see how in right now we're
doing their restriction now is ten
models instead of five minutes so this
is what you can do if you just want to
explore the number of models instead of
getting given at a time you can do so
too so we don't have to specify the the
time anymore but we're expressing fine I
just want ten models and that's it so as
I mentioned before we will get the ten
models and then we get to Stockton
symbols again we're specifying the seed
we have the project name and we're doing
that stopping metric and so meaning that
if the rmse does not improve we will
just stop training the model and then
the sort metric and this is for the
leaderboard so we'll get the leaderboard
sorted based on the rmse and again we're
just giving it the the X the Y in the
training so are there any questions so
if we don't have any questions we'll
wait a little bit
just we'll take about five minutes to
same as the first one
yes let me look for it so here you have
the documentation
so you have to go symmetric function yes
no problem so so we have the eternal
here you can find right here so in the
documentation there is a lot of
information that you can find so if you
if you wanted to know all the parameters
that you can change here it's a here
they all of them and they have a short
description for you to study them and
also here are examples that you can use
and I just want to show you here like
the models that it ring yes
oh I'm sorry sorry it's not better yeah
so so they're frequent frequently asked
questions here test tells you in details
which models are are been training so
you will get three previous specify XE
boos gbm's and then GLM's and you can go
through through this but this is just
telling you which algorithms are going
to be trained when you train the the
other ML yes
oh I'm sorry so it's the the it's in
here it's in the in our this is the the
documentation page yes I'm sorry
okay so so do you have any any more
questions so while we yes
yeah so so did you get to this to this
part of the music yeah so so what
so I'm sorry what super Christian Oh
but yeah this is where this will tell
you how I'm the missing data is handled
in sure
so any more questions yes
yes so as I mentioned before we have the
word to back and if we go to two
algorithms you will see let me just show
you right here so we're too big this
will transform the text into vectors
that your algorithm can use to train yes
you can oh you want me to do it right
now
oh yes yes yes yes that's right
so we have in in the slides
so it's done so here are very a lot of
tutorials so once you receive the slides
feel free to to check all these links
and you will find all types of tutorials
and there are some some tutorials on NLP
as well so you can check that out and I
think it's done so is anyone waiting
okay sorry
so if we go back to the Jupiter notebook
we will print the little board again and
we see that the stocton symbol again I
performed the the other models but we
see that the X eBoost is the the the
model follows the the the Stockton
symbol and somebody as was asking about
the how do you access different model so
here's one way that you can do it so you
will get all the model like this from
you to leader board and then you will
specify it so in this case I'm trying
I'm retrieving the XC boost one which
was this
right here so I just changed it and and
to elaborate a little bit more on this
we can and also in this life I mentioned
that rml can use can be used to
establish a baseline so in this case say
we're interested in into these sexy
boots right so we can print this all
these parameters and we can see that the
the default value was 50 but it actually
changed to 162 and the backstep changed
from 6 to 10 the learning rate also
changed as well as a sample rate so this
is how you could actually do a local
search so say you really saw that the XC
boost did really good with these values
so maybe you can do I random or a
Cartesian grid search for values maybe
close to that the max depth close to
maybe 10 so you can do like 8 9 10 11 12
and see if it changes if it still keeps
changing or do you get the best value
with that so that's what I meant at the
beginning that you can use it as a
baseline so this is another command to
print all of the parameters although
it's not really nice so if you really
wanted to look at all of them you can do
this but if you just want to check out
specific parameters you can you can also
do this then yeah we can call it so it's
an extra boost but the name is a GBM so
don't don't be misled by that this is
the same thing that we just did before
we'll get in this summary for our our
model performance and you can do the
plot for the training scoring history
and then again the model performance
based on the test set you will see the
rmse the mie the MSE and all these
values related to the regression this is
the same that I was saying the model
performance based on the test set and we
can do predictions as well and here I'm
combining the interest rate with the
with the predictions that way we can
check so so this is what I wanted to go
over for for the for the Python so are
there any questions before I show the
flow interface so okay go back to
aquarium and I'll explain a little bit
more why I wanted to show flow and click
on the link with flow
okay so so it's everyone slow their load
good so go back to aquarium and click on
the link that says h2o flow URL and that
will take you to the flow so so in here
this can be used as a complement to your
Jupiter na book because in here you can
see everything that we just did right
now so if we do get frames you can see
everything that was created in our
Jupiter notebook if you scroll down you
will see the the data set that we
imported right here so there's a we can
we can do is plates on it let's let's
let's do it real quick because it's the
last thing I will do so if you follow me
when you do this blue frame you just do
the ratio point eight and point two and
call it trained and call the second one
test and change your seat and you create
a small so again I went to get frames
here in the assistance module get frames
and then you will see all this
locate the loan level 50k that hex and
click on it and then you can do a split
and split it into training and test with
0.8 ratio and and you create so now we
have trained and test right so you can
also retrieve all the models that you
did so if we go back up to the to the
assistance you can get the models in
here you will see all the models that we
we just worked on or that the animal
generated so you have the DRF one and if
you scroll down you'll see all the
all the models that we created in in our
Jupiter notebook so a quick way to to do
a demo in flow if you're not very
familiar with your with Python or are
you can even use this and this is very
user friendly so if we give it a name
which we can just call it ml classifier
and then we'll select a training that's
all the training set the response column
was delinquent I will leave this to as
they are and then we will ignore the
prepayment column product type and
prepay you can include a delinquent
again this s you will actually in
ignores it automatically but if you just
want to make sure then you can do this
they intellect for you to the leader
board for him I'm sorry for the leader
board frames like the test I click on
balance classes and you can leave it
empty and this is these are the the
parameters that I was saying I mentioned
before this is a class sampling factor
so you will sample you will look for
this values to improve your your your
performance and here you you can exclude
the out goes and let's just run it for
for two minutes because we're running
out of time
so 120 seconds
let's leave the early stopping on auto
the leaderboard and everything can be
left the same and chose 242 for the seat
again and build the model so right now
you will see the other models running
and this is doing the same thing that we
just did in Python but is doing in
inflow and as I said before this can be
used as a compliment to do to your your
superior because you can create the
model in Jupiter and just blow all the
outputs in here and
we'll see this in a bit once this is
done the two minutes so any questions in
here in the flow yes
try to it didn't work oh it didn't work
for you
so so when you launch or when you
initialize the closer you get something
similar to this or do you get an extra
message okay so the problem was
something with the initialization so if
you want we won't have time by that but
if you if you start the lab again you
can end the lap and start it and chose
initialize your closer so once you get
this you should be ready or your flow a
link should work I'm not really sure why
it didn't work but I probably had to do
with the initialization so so going back
to to flow here we can click on View and
it will give us the leaderboard again
and you you will see like all the work
that it did and the training so
tomorrow's actually we didn't give it
enough time
okay so I'll show you with this talent
symbol so so this is the model that we
created before and
see yes so so it gives you all this a
point for for each of the models so you
can see all of this oh so this is what I
was referring so you can you can
actually create the models in Python and
just come to your flow instance you can
go over all the parameters in this case
you will see the base models are all the
EXCI booze and this is all that we saw
and then you will get the arrow seeker
for for your training matrix and also
for the validation one and if you wanted
to to change the cut criterion you can
do so by threshold or you can do it by
by metric so in this case we choose the
f1 you will see all the actual values of
your metrics based on that threshold and
also the confusion matrix based on on on
the same threshold you can also take a
look at the gains and lift table or
graph as well as more output the column
types and as you see in flow you can you
can do all this and something that I
didn't mention in the in the in the u
pillar is that you can download the edit
mojo and make predictions on a new data
set and this will be much much faster
you can just import it and then you can
just download it and then import it to
your Jupiter or Orion or to instant and
you can make predictions on your data
set so so this is all I wanted to cover
so I want to give this ten minutes to
questions so if you have any questions
please feel free to to ask so so yeah
yes
so yeah my understanding is that they
will send it to you yes so any any more
questions so I just want to show you
something so if you go to to this github
repo this tutorial will be posted soon
on there
h2o so right now I will I will still
working on it but I'm if you want to go
back and redo it and actually try the
the flow part on your own you can also
do it so this is the repo so github
slash suo AI slide side tutorials that
means you made a little bit so in here
you will see different folder for driver
let's say I this is a I think the
commercial platform but here we have the
tutorials for a sewer right now we only
have one but maybe like in two weeks we
will have the a dremmel tutorial and our
regression use case tutorial as well so
feel free to check this out we have a
account in these tutorials you will be
able to follow it and maybe do it on
your own machine if you want but you can
also use aquarium whenever you want now
that you have your account you can just
start the labs and and do what we just
did today so so any questions yes
I'm not familiar with that sorry
so so so here's a benchmark so I can
tell you I can give you my opinion but
here's the benchmark and you can
actually click on it once you receive it
and you will see how how this person
goes into details about all the results
and and and the comparison between our
h2o and other platforms so so actual
provides you with high performance and
also a very accurate models so I just
don't don't want to say that these are
the best but this is a suo is one of the
leading based machine learning platforms
right now so so you can see so going
back to the benchmark now that you
mention it so in this specific case
I sure was faster and also it was the
second most accurate in the in this in
this specific experiment so feel free to
go over this document and and decide so
I saw two more questions yes
I'm not very familiar with that but I
haven't seen that in the in the in the
algorithm so far yes
so I personally haven't done that yet
but uh I can get back to you on that
yeah yeah sorry so any more questions
yes yes
yes sir
did you get to this page
okay so so we do have the documentation
you can look for Java and this is one of
the things that are you will see so
here's the documentation for the Java so
I'm pretty sure it will be just to see
if it loads well yeah we do provided the
commutation so it will be here right
here so here you you'll have this all
the information that we have on that
yeah so yeah I'm not really sure if we
have a very detailed documentation on
Java at this point but I if you're a
child to me I can look for this
information with our engineers and I can
get back to you on this but this is what
we have this you can find some
information here in the documentation
section so any last question yes mm-hmm
yeah yeah you can so I think that's it
so yeah we're done
thank you
[Applause]